women Santa and chains I'm going to
destroy that peepee I'm already like
I've gotten out yet I'm already
establishing an idea I'm pretty close on
glass do you have an idea I think my
idea is pretty damn good we're doing a
visual effects competition between pee
or 900 finally establish which software
is better well I mean okay no no no no
there's no room for logic here 3dsmax
your blender blender okay well I guess
we don't have to do this though okay
here's the thing though is that like you
can do all these things you can have
like soft bunny physics hard vices it's
like stretching to that fluid dynamics
oh all right I'm now getting nervous
it's like I really want to make a cool
image but I don't know if we could do it
in an hour okay
rules of the game okay we have an hour
what we're doing is still a mental and
that's it and I was like our more you
ready I'm intending to actually import
one or two 3d models I'm intending to do
that as well so rule is that was like
someone was just like jumping around in
the pipe now your water
hello hello houses art pub super bizarre
now the random moment of an a number 58
we've made carbon fiber knives yeah
that's the coolest thing ever but now we
have one more carbon fiber thing to make
absolutely let's see if they can guess
it just from doing this ready and what
is that oh gosh what is it okay Oh
basically it's been fight from cutting
the 9th earlier we don't have a blade on
the bandsaw the bandsaw just was
straight up to don't even cook it low so
it's a line cut that it was starting to
beer what else are we got it all right
I'll have to use an angle grinder and
some cutoff wheel for cutting this
project
did you see how much carbon fiber does
that work reminisce Danna and chains I'm
going to destroy that pizza my view
right now is I'm going to take a say
you're in New York and you're looking at
maybe an apartment from the street and
I'm going to take that and when I get
circular I feel like I have reached
perfection with kids here is absurdly
talented am i nervous yeah what on the
line what do you mean my job is in Jeff
Ellis someone younger than you that
means he can last longer doing the same
job you're gonna figure out how to start
up your champion first off ivory I've
already tried convincing Peter to drop
out of college and just come work for us
full-time leave a comment down below as
he should
so one thing often does really well is
simulate the light so I'm thinking what
if I create a dark force each scene with
lots of trees in like big boulders and
there's two minecraft zombies walking
around no yes so they're zombies from
that game the gut they've got
lightsabers and they're telling peering
around and stuff around a boulder and
time the boulder is a massive black
widow spider the general idea is I want
to have a couple minecraft song
the wood was starting the wood core was
starting to smoke a little bit I
actually left the whoa
wow it's smoking
toasty so to do that on these three
what's all that is that's access in case
I messed up always be prepared
I'm actually quite pleased with a little
angle grinder though I think that was
actually the right tool digital to this
so there will be diagonal cuts I just
need a measure out where they are and
then once I've cut out just a little
finish sanding some of the edges and
should be finished because they're both
go to different things and it's got the
wisdom it's a wise man's game here knows
his way around physics emulation really
well I think randoms way around
rendering really well I said to each
other strengths or weaknesses what over
tiny develop these little tricks that
you can drop into the chops to make it
look good and I think wrens got more
tricks up his sleeve than Peter does
these days I definitely agree so what I
was just selling them for smokers from
wood it's not like carbon ducks oh no no
need to be alarmed be like yeah good
pretty solid do math on go get Danny go
there it's pretty cool that everything
you ever could have hoped it to be a
good sign we should put it was building
a sentence firing guns here yeah
actually uh Corvette Chevy is that's a
lot bigger than I expected awesome at
saying something like that yeah big but
yeah you guys Beezus crazy I don't know
yeah that's very now yeah I mean for
whatever we look with praxis so there's
no choice Daniel
Brennen
[Music]
mr. contender the best pickles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all the textures are completely unlinked
already part of the ways don't worry
about can't hop in cribs modeling yeah I
can't I can't be doing this right now
man no
come on traitor I think I know what
you're looking for words for it
[Music]
no they're textures I made a zombie
textures that I built for a video we did
last year these are open anytime buddy
in the script
it's going around unforeseen
consequences blanks in which output
unforeseen problems we're good we're
good
36 minutes no this is not good I was
trying to use the minecraft audience I
will find do you want to see how we're
gonna recovered screw nuts
what you probably won't get a subscribe
going word we are we trying to break
carbon fiber and I guess we are
Chechen
this is why would hurt fertility
Richwood and
Oh actually the prizes in crack without
ah the corpsman attack yeah the carpet I
mean it there's no proof that's a pretty
good argument to break from the camera
flyover
I'm sorry's not an oil I forgot the same
that time I will not give up looks like
you're gonna have to subscribe to see
what happens to run
[Music]